we've had today some of the details
about the chancellor rishi sunak and his
philanthropic giving now the chancellor
is in the spotlight at the moment
because he
uh gave a spring statement which many on
the tory side as well as the opposition
said perhaps wasn't generous enough to
those uh particularly on the lowest
incomes uh despite a massive tax cut at
the heart of it um so there's been quite
a focus in recent days about rishi sunak
the man who is of course a
multi-millionaire in his own right and
married to the daughter of a billionaire
sky news has uh has learned today that
rishi sunak has given over a hundred
thousand pounds to winchester college
now this is the school where he was head
boy the donations to this college have
been going on since the point at which
he became chancellor so we have a
chancellor who both simultaneously funds
through his steering of public money uh
the state school system but also has
been perfect uh personally uh donating
uh to winchester college one of the most
prestigious schools in the country which
has uh fees of over 44 000 pounds uh
we've spoken to the treasury about this
the chancellor's spokesman confirms that
rishi and his wife have donated related
to numerous charities and philanthropic
causes for many years and will continue
to do so these donations are made to
fund scholarships for children who would
not otherwise have the opportunity to go
to winchester so i suspect that there'll
be some interest in how the chancellor
spreads his large ass clearly has plenty
of money a number of properties uh there
was some criticism of the way that he
dealt with the post-spring statement uh
photo opportunities some of which you
can see now he later struggled a little
bit to use the contactless card uh to
pay for it which i think we're just
about to see there was also a moment uh
where he filled up a car that turned out
not to be his all of that has turned the
spotlight on rishi sunak and the way
that he conducts himself and the wealth
that he has amassed uh but as i say sky
news today finding out that um he has
been funding uh bursaries scholarships
at winchester's college one of the most
prestigious uh public schools in the
country uh and has donated to them over
a hundred thousand pounds including
making some of those donations in his
period as chancellor